once or twice a month the private art
collection at Gibbs farm in New Zealand
opens up to the public the tickets are
free but they go very quickly the art
here in this collection isn't just
paintings on a wall it's land art made
by moving vast amounts of soil and earth
or it's sculpture on a scale seen only
in a few places in the world and the
most famous piece in the collection is
this horizons by Neil Dawson 15 metres
wide the height of a four-story building
depending on who you ask
it either resembles a piece of
corrugated iron blown in from a distant
farm or a giant paper tissue that's been
thrown away and it looks like a cartoon
that's been sketched on the landscape
but it's made of welded steel and I
think the thing that sells the optical
illusion best is that little spike that
little incomplete fold which is yeah
actually a big spike of metal but from a
distance your brain just doesn't see
that this was one of the first pieces
commissioned for Gibbs farm and it was
commissioned Allan Gibbs who owns this
farm and the art on it is one of the
wealthiest folks to come from New
Zealand and rather than collect art that
has already been made
he hired internationally famous artists
and sculptors and said in short here's
some money make me a thing that'll go
here this farm is basically one rich
millionaires playground
Hank it was originally bought as a
fairly remote place to drive a
collection of vintage military vehicles
the art came second in a 20-17 interview
with The Wall Street Journal Gibbs said
it's not a public park it's not a
charity I'm happy to let people see it
he said but it's still primarily a
family holiday retreat of course
everything here is well documented you
can look online and see every sculpture
from basically every angle possible but
if you actually want to stand here and
experience that optical illusion for
yourself if the feeling of being here in
person is important to you well
Gibbs farm is only open occasionally
you'll have to join the rest of us in
the queue for tickets
you